[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen how's
everybody doing today before we get
started I just want to give a heads-up
to everybody the future of Jon Snow part
2 has been released but it appears that
less than half of you have actually
watched it so I'm assuming YouTube
didn't notify any of you when I released
a video but it does look like all of you
did watch part 1 of the Jon Snow video
that I did with the other members of the
golden company so if some of you have
been wondering why you haven't seen part
2 yet I just wanted to let you know that
the video is on the channel so
definitely go check that out as soon as
you have time I will put that link down
in the description for you but today's
video will be a little bit different
than my previous ones there are a few
different things I want to discuss with
you I wouldn't necessarily call these
theories but there are a few different
thoughts that I've had bouncing around
my head there are 3 different things I
want to talk about because I am curious
to see what some other people think and
instead of me making three different
videos I figured I would just talk about
all of them right here since I don't
have enough evidence to support them
they might sound ridiculous or bizarre
but I think they are fun things to
explore the first thing I want to talk
about is Thoris of Mir and Melisandre
specifically both of these characters
had the ability to bring someone back
from the dead in the books
beric Dondarrion also has this power
when he gives lady Catelyn the kiss of
life which then resurrects or as Lady
Stoneheart
we haven't seen Barrack do anything like
this in the television show but he
himself has risen from the dead on
multiple occasions
thanks to Thor's of mirror and we also
saw Melisandre do the same thing to Jon
Snow
but what I've been wondering is how
strong or these powers that Thoreau said
Melisandre has what else could they
potentially bring back from the dead
let's take the night Kings Army for
instance the whites to be exact the
whites are the seemingly mindless like
zombies that the xix uses to man his
army the night king can also raise the
skeletons of dead bodies but obviously I
don't think there would be much
that Thoris and Melisandre could do
considering there is nothing left to
those bodies but what about the whites
that are still fully intact similar to
the ones that we saw at Hart home after
the massacre at hardhome the night King
was able to raise all of those fresh
dead bodies most of which had similar
fatal wounds that Jon Snow and beric
Dondarrion had when they were killed and
resurrected so I've been wondering if
Melisandre and Thoris of Mir would be
able to regain control of a dead person
that the knight King has under his
control let me give you an example let's
say when the war for the dawn starts in
the night king and his army come
marching south decimating town after
town there will more than likely come a
time to where the making is able to kill
one of the main characters and turn them
into meat for his army do you think it's
possible that Thoris or Melisandre could
be able to bring that person back that
way they aren't trapped under the knight
Kings control imagine if someone like
Tyrion was killed then resurrected as a
white that would absolutely suck but all
hope might not be lost
perhaps with forests and Melisandre
maybe even if they both work together
could possibly bring that person back if
they were able to resurrect the white
they could potentially even gain some
insight into how the knight king's army
worked that would be very interesting in
my opinion I know this might sound
far-fetched but I've been thinking about
it and I wanted to see what other people
thought about this too I think the idea
of resurrected and white would be pretty
cool and speaking of the main characters
turn on in the white this leads me to
something else I was thinking about the
one way we know the whites can be killed
for sure is with fire now do not get the
whites confused with the White Walkers
the White Walkers can be killed with
dragonglass in Valyrian steel but the
whites must be killed with fire now who
was one person in the show that cannot
be killed with fire that's the Narus
Targaryen we have seen her survived
multiple fires so how hard would it be
to kill Daenerys if she turned into a
white would her fire resistant still
hold up if she was meet in the night
king's army she could potentially be
damn near unstoppable if she went to the
other side because I know some people
think Daenerys is going to die at the
wall ever since they shown us her vision
at the house of the undying and if this
is the case in Daenerys
does die at the wall then the chances of
her being risen by the night King
dramatically increase and if she still
remained fire-resistant how the hell
could she be stopped we're not even sure
if dragon fire can kill her but comment
below and give me your opinion on this
do you think if Danny was turned into a
white that she would still be fire
resistant like we've seen in the
previous seasons or do you think once
she's turned to white and she's
susceptible to fire like all the other
whites I'm kind of curious about this
there's one other thing I want to
mention too and it's about the Horn of
winter legend says that German who was
the king-beyond-the-wall blew the Horn
of winter and supposedly woke Giants
free folks also believed that the horn
can bring down the wall but we were
introduced to a horn that was north of
the wall the horn that was found by gran
and Sam at the fist of the first men
that was buried with some dragon glass
as of right now Sam has this horn with
him at the Citadel but no one is exactly
sure what all this one can do but I want
to throw something out there that I
haven't heard anyone else say before
there are a lot of things in this story
that parallel one another and that
balance to this world similar to how
this is a Song of Ice and Fire
some say the Song of Ice and Fire can be
a metaphor for the night King in the
Dragons one being ice and one being fire
thinking on those kind of terms what if
both horns in the story can control both
Ice and Fire
there was another horn called dragon
binder Euron says it can control dragons
so what if the Horn of winter can
control the night king now I know that
probably sounds crazy but I think it
would also make sense perhaps it could
instead control the night Kings army as
far as we know the two most powerful
weapons we have seen so far are the
dragons of the night King I think it
would be kind of cool that if one one
can control one ultimate weapon then the
other horn can do the same thing for the
opposite side think of it as sort of
like a dog whistle imagine if you blew
the Horn of winter and it stopped the
night Kings army in its tracks or
imagined it flowing the Horn of winter
made all the White Walkers shatter into
a thousand pieces of ice the Horn of
winter can potentially have powers that
no one knows about it was once thought
that the free folk had this horn in the
only thing that stopped them from
blowing it was because they didn't want
to bring down the wall because they
wanted to
south of the wall and they also needed
the wall to protect them from the others
too so how crazy would it be if all this
time the horn could have actually solved
the problem with the night King and not
just woken Giants or brought down the
wall but keep in mind I'm not saying
that these are my actual theories or
that I'm saying any of this stuff will
happen it was just some [ __ ] that I was
thinking about so let me know what you
think about these or any of these
possible do you think a red priest could
potentially resurrect the white if Danny
was turned into a white do you think she
would still be fire resistant and do you
think the Horn of winter could
potentially control the night king
and/or his army but before I go I want
to show some love to everyone that has
helped me out and shown their support
everyone patreon I cannot thank you all
enough even the one dollar pledge is
held Thank You Christopher Thomas Travis
Darren brand sir Thomas cipher shoulder
carry marine Kyle Jeannette golden girl
daughter of Ice and Fire
Nick Jean USMC James indie sports car
podcast and the Theon defense squad I
want to thank you all so much I
appreciate the support I will see you
down in the comment section bye
you